[Music]  for the pork and pork balls in a bowl  add pork mince then add finely chopped  prawns diced ginger and chopped chives  [Music]  season  and roll into ping-pong sized balls  for the broth meat fresh stock and add  star anis oyster sauce soy sauce and  sliced ginger  gently simmer fry the pork and prawn  balls in a pan until golden then  transfer to the bubbling broth  I have handfuls of spinach then serve  top with finely sliced spring onions a  gorgeous healthy dish that uses great  value ingredients with amazing results  pork and prawn balls in aromatic broth  ready to eat in under 20 minutes lying  there and a line going across put the  point of the knife in and just push  through step on is the most expensive  spice in the world made from the dried  stigma of croak